حياه افضل واطول جسم ارشق شعورا بالرضاعه
هذا ما يبحث عنه الجميع لكن كل ذلك يمر
بالتغذيه وكل يوم هناك فكره جديده ونظريه
جديده بالفعل الدراسه امريكيه جديده نشرت
في موقع اكسبريس تقول ان الحد من تناول
طعام لفتره اطول وتاخير الافطار حتى ظهيره
ربما يمنح الانسان عمرا اطول ل 20 عاما
لكن هذه دراسه تجد من يعرضها كالعاده في
بحث اخر لفريق طبي في جامعه
العلماء ان الصيام المتقطع هو الاسم
المعتمد لهذا النوع من الحميه يفشل في
الكثير من الاحيان للمساعده على انقاصدها
الدراسه الصادمه هذه وجدت في النهايه ان
تغيير توقيت الطعام ليس مهما بقدر اهميه
السعرات الحراريه التي يتناولها الانسان
التي تساعد في التخلص من الوزن بفعاليه
اكبر
[موسيقى]
الى لميس
موقع اكسبريس جاء على شكل نصائح نسبيه من
الطبيبه الامريكيه جوليا جونز والتي تؤكد
ان تاخير تناول طعام الافطار او ما يعرف
بالصيام المتقطع هو نمط حياه يساعد كثيرا
على الحفاظ على الجسم بشكل مثالي ويطير
العمر طبيبات
نحويه 16 ساعه من اجل ان يسمح للجهاز
الهضمي والمسرات الخلوي الاخرى ان تنظم
نفسها وترتب وظائفها لكن على النقود فان
دراسه جامعه ان الصيام لا يمكن ان يكون
الطريق المثاليه للجسم البشري لانه عند
الاكل قد ياكل الانسان بشكل زائد عن حاجته
وبالتالي لن يكون هناك اي فائده منه فكره
الفريق البحث في جون سابقا تقول ان الاهم
من الصيام هو حساب عدد السعرات الحراريه
المستخدمه في الاكل وهي الطريقه الافضل من
اجل قيام بحميه تساعد على الحصول على وزن
الاقل
[موسيقى]
طيب نادي لو خيروك بنت اخير وجبه الفطور
او بين الصيام المتقطع او بنت خذي راحتك
بالاكل شو بتختاري اختار الثالث
مع انه في فوائد طبيه وعلميه للصيام
[موسيقى]
لا اتغدى اتغدى وزير واتعشى فقير اه انا
هيك انا منها المقوله